[Music]
all right guys
remember what we're looking for and
don't trust
anyone
[Music]
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is raya
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore peace
we must find the last dragon i wish to
join this
fellowship of butt hickory
let's go we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
[Music]
six years of searching please let this
be it
who said that we really need your help
ah i'm gonna be real with you
i'm not like the best dragon have you
ever done like a group project but
there's like that one kid who didn't
pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grave uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
good
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just changed dragons can do that look
how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premiere access
march 5th
bye